We want you to participate in the World Economic
Forum on the Middle East and North Africa.
At the meeting held in Marrakech we will conduct
four sessions around key topics concerning the region.
And we would like your feedback
on some of these questions:
What top initiatives can the US and the Muslim world
introduce to change the dynamics of the relationship?
What are the top strategic drivers of deeper
engagement of leading Asian economies with North Africa?
What are the top regional initiatives that can foster
systemic resilience vis-à-vis evolving global risks?
What top innovations would retool the
examination systems to drive education reform?
We want you to comment on the proposals made by
leading experts to our questions or to add new ones.
Submit your feedback in text or with a video no
longer than 2 minutes to YouTube.com/Davos.
You can also vote for your favourite submissions.
Your feedback will be incorporated in the
proceedings of the World Economic Forum
on the Middle East and North Africa with some of
the most powerful and influential people in the world.
Go to YouTube.com/Davos to join the conversation.